bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
deuxième échec pour boris eltsine son
candidat victor tchernomirdine au poste
premier ministre refusé par le parlement
la douma cet après-midi amélioration de
l'état de santé de jean pierre
chevènement le ministre de l'intérieur
est sortie de la phase de choc selon un
communiqué de l'hôpital du val de grâce
le parti communiste des réformes plus
radical né et réaffirme son appartenance
à la majorité plurielle explications
avec notre invité robert lu les livres
scolaires mis en cause dès les premiers
jours de la rentrée leur nombre et leur
contenu ne serait pas adapté aux besoins
des élèves
la romancière anglaise mary higgins
clark au festival du cinéma de deauville
rencontre avec cet auteur de polars à
succès pour la deuxième fois à moscou
les membres de la chambre basse du
parlement la douma ont rejeté la
candidature de victor tchernomirdine des
communistes n'ont rien voulu entendre
ils pourraient même appuyer une
procédure de destitution de boris
eltsine
ce matin pourtant le président russe
avait tenté d'amadouer les députés en
proposant que monsieur tchernomirdine
soit nommé pour une période d'essai
récit de cette journée à moscou avec
gilles rabin
8 qui depuis toujours vivait entouré de
serviteurs et de courtisans il n'a
jamais été aussi seul à l'ouverture de
la séance victor tchernomirdine sait
déjà qu'il ne sera pas investi tout est
joué depuis le matin depuis l'échec de
la table ronde de la dernière chance où
l'opposition a refusé net tout
marchandage autour des fauteuil de
ministre
boris eltsine croyez que l'opposition
communiste avait cédé in extremis encore
une fois elle l'a toujours fait
jusqu'ici
il s'est trompé alors quand il monte à
la tribune pour plaider une dernière
fois son dossier qui en nomme erding
manque de conviction et sa conclusion
sur pense que le nombre des plus profond
de moi et je demande pardon à ceux que
j'ai blessé s'en vouloir
pendant cette prévision suit une longue
bataille de procédure sur la façon de
botter vote à bulletin secret favorable
trahison de même chez les communistes
bottes publics ou ceux qui ont vendu
leur vote serait obligé de se démasquer
trois fois de suite
on votera sur le vote en vain quand
arrive le tour du chef de la coalition
communistes guennadi ziouganov ne fait
pas dans la dentelle
la situation d'aujourd'hui nous
rappellent celles de la russie en
janvier 1917 la n10 art de son premier
ministre et de raspoutine et aujourd'hui
et rasputin de yale signer
tchernomirdine ce sont les banquiers
vient l'heure du vote comme prévu la
douma vote et construction de mire dean
la mairie de gilles rabin à moscou
qu'elle est le pronostic est il se
passer maintenant
eh bien écoutez il ya deux scénarios
possibles le premier scénario c'est
celui de la dissolution soit que le bras
de fer actuel entre le kremlin et la
douma a jusqu'à son terme jusqu'au
troisième vote d'investiture la semaine
prochaine soit que boris eltsine décide
de dissoudre la douma avant ce que la
constitution ne lui interdit pas
deuxième scénario boris elstine change
de candidat au poste de premier ministre
et ce soir à moscou un nom émerge par
dessus tout les autres celui des guides
primakov l'actuel ministre des affaires
étrangères l'ancien chef du fsb savez
c'est la nouvelle appellation pour le
gb déjà sous gorbatchev y avait dix
primakov qui est un ancien très haut
dignitaire de l'époque soviétique était
l'homme de toutes les missions
impossibles alors boris eltsine et a
annulé son déplacement au kazakhstan est
ce que ça signifie quelque chose de
particulier ou pas ça évidemment en
rapport avec la crise vous savez
aujourd'hui on a vu boris elstine après
l'échec de la table ronde proposée aux
députés une sorte de domination à
l'essai de son premier ministre après
examen de passage aux six mois devant la
douma
on l'a vu une heure après signé l'accord
politique sur la réduction drastique de
ses pouvoirs
bref ce n'est plus le tsar boris sûr de
lui et dominateur et s'ils s'accrochent
toujours à son trône à sa présidence sa
démission morale elle est impressionnant
merci gines est dans l'incapacité de
limiter les conséquences de la crise
financière pour la population russe le
président de la banque centrale à moscou
a envoyé sa lettre de démission à boris
eltsine
il est vrai que les pagnes populaires
n'est plus protégé compte tenu de la
faiblesse de la monnaie le rouble en
trois semaines le rouble a perdu plus de
60% de sa valeur dans la vie quotidienne
les russes commencent à sérieusement
sentir les effets de la crise y compris
pour leur consommation alimentaire
nous nous sommes rendus à dukovski à une
heure de route de moscou dans cette
ville industrielle la pénurie se fait
sentir très grave
reportage dorothée lyrique didier da
bienvenue au marché de joukovski
personne n'a songé à enlever la
banderole personne ne songe plus
désormais à sourire hier le lait
concentré à huit rounds
aujourd'hui il a 15 comment je vais
vivement j'ai 380 euros par mois
les prix d'être des voleurs regardez
dans quel état le peuple c'est pas la
faute des commerçants on va faire la
guerre c'est que ce qu'il l'aurait
c'était ce qu'il ne rêve pas faire
regarder nos enfants ils n'ont plus
gagné sur le marché l'ena est bien
connue elle est informaticienne mais
pour relever ses cinq enfants elle est
devenue commerçante à cause de la crise
depuis trois jours ces filles ont
délaissé la fac de psycho pour gagner
quelques roubles de plus ici les
vendeurs sont médecins ingénieurs ou
ouvriers à cause du dollar ils peuvent à
nouveau tout perdre
regardez les étalages sont vides il ya
plus rien à vendre
tout est en train de faire mais voilà
notre vie rien à voir avec la vie
d'avant tu paul f nick fusée titan juch
offs qui était la ville phare de
l'aéronautique
dix mille employés travailler dans ses
usines aujourd'hui moins de 3000 et ils
ne sont plus payés depuis des mois une
longue dégradation et en quinze jours un
naufrage ça ce sont les files d'attentes
pour acheter de la lessive et du savant
ambiante on n'aura plus rien pour se
laver et rayant pour laver nos vêtements
et on va se retrouver à l'âge de pierre
léna n'avait pas vu ça depuis la fin de
la pérestroïka c'était il ya sept ans
l'âge de ces gamins qui découvrent pour
la première fois les pénuries en
république démocratique du congo
les rebelles annoncent de nouveaux
bombardements sur calais nié dans le sud
est du pays la rébellion pose des
conditions un cessez-le-feu
ces représentants sont à victoria falls
dans l'ouest du zimbabwe pour un sommet
de discussion face une délégation
conduite par le président kabila à ce
sommet participent également les
présidents de l'angola de la namibie du
rwanda et de l'ouganda
et puis à noter que l'envoyé spécial de
libération jean hatzfeld a été agressé
hier par deux militaires congolais à
kinshasa au large de la province
canadienne de la nouvelle écosse les
recherches se poursuivent dans
l'atlantique par plusieurs dizaines de
mètres de fond pour tenter de retrouver
les corps des victimes de l'accident de
l'avion de la swiss air mais aussi des
débris de cet avion ce matin signale a
été capté par un sous-marin ce serait
celui émis par la deuxième boîte noire
de l'avion la première avait été repêché
hier reportage halifax de notre envoyé
spécial
dominique derda
sur le quai de la base militaire
d'halifax loin des regards indiscrets en
décharge les débris de l'appareil
récupérés en mer ces quatre derniers
jours les plus gros ne dépasserait pas 1
mètre de long le puzzle sera difficile à
reconstituer mais grâce à l'une des deux
boîtes noires retrouvées hier par les
plongeurs de la marine canadienne
on devrait bientôt en savoir un peu plus
sur les causes de la catastrophe
cet enregistrement
s'il a bien fonctionné devrait nous
donner une centaine d'informations sur
lesquels nous allons pouvoir travailler
mais si une panne complète de
l'alimentation électrique s'étaient
produites six minutes avant le crash
comme certains ici l'imaginent il se
pourrait bien alors que la boîte noire
elle aussi ait cessé de fonctionner
pour large de peggy's cove les
recherches pour suivre la seconde boîte
noire a bien été localisés et en aurait
repéré par 60 mètres de fond trois gros
morceaux de la carlingue
il pourrait contenir les corps d'autres
passagers un bateau brute américain est
attendu demain il devrait permettre
aussi la mer n'est pas trop forte
d'arracher aux fonds marins
les pièces les plus longs en ce week-end
de fête du travail ce lundi est férié au
canada des centaines de badauds suivent
à la jumelle au caméscope l'incessant
va-et-vient des vedettes et les
appareils de la marque
on a l'impression de faire partie de
cette tragédie et puis on enfance
famille également
mais on pense que ceci à un point d'eux
pour se recueillir à bel ombre
c'est un très bel endroit
tanguy ce qu est l une des destinations
touristiques les plus populaires de la
côte
son nom pour tous ici est désormais
celui d'un vaste cimetière marin en fin
d'après midi à l'hôpital du val de grâce
à paris un communiqué médical annonçait
que l'état de santé du ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur jean pierre
chevènement s'était améliorée dans les
dernières 48 heures monsieur jean pierre
chevènement est plongé dans le coma
depuis mercredi dernier et jusqu'à
présent les autorités médicales se sont
refusé à tout pronostic
dans ce dernier communiqué pourtant il
est fait état de la sortie de la phase
de choc
l'explication jean daniel flaysakier et
alors je vous donne le communiqué du 7
septembre
l'état de santé de monsieur jean pierre
chevènement s'est améliorée dans les
dernières 48 heures un cap important a
été franchi avec la sortie de la phase
de choc pour probant dit toutes les
défaillances viscérale vita sont
actuellement en voie de régression
les questions qui se posent à nous
maintenant son but par l' évaluation
plus fine de l'état neurologique et
d'autre part la date et les modalités du
sevrage de l'appareillage d'assistance
un état de choc
c'est ainsi qu'on appelle les
conséquences de l'accident a listé zik
du ministre de l'intérieur
pour les spécialistes des services de
réanimation il faut alors surveiller au
plus près la grave défaillance de divers
organes les reins d'abord incapable des
purs le sang heureusement dispose d'
unité d'hémodialyse 1re artificielle
capable de suppléer en partie la
défaillance de l'organe autre risque
voir la température du corps échapper au
contrôle du cerveau elle peut monter à
plus de 43 degrés faire courir un risque
vital mais le risque majeur c'était
surtout le fonctionnement du foie c'est
organes impliqués dans 99% des réactions
de l'organisme fabrique en particulier
les substances indispensable à la
coagulation sanguine sa défaillance peut
faire courir un risque majeur
d'hémorragie la récupération partielle
des fonction hépatique et rénale est un
signe encourageant mais tant que ces
organes non pas recouvré leurs capacités
en pierre on peut dire qu'on a gagné une
bataille mais qu'on n'a pas encore loin
s'en faut même gagner définitivement la
guerre
ce matin le secrétaire d'état jean
jacques queyranne qui assure l'intérim
de jean pierre chevènement président est
un colloque du service de coopération
technique de police
ce que l'on appelle les attachés de
police et bénéficie d'un statut
diplomatique dans les ambassades et
coopère avec leurs collègues étrangers
en matière de sécurité
ce sont des spécialistes de la
criminalité internationale
il y aurait près de 400 fonctionnaires a
pêché deux policiers officiers de
liaison français en poste à l'étranger
parmi les participants à ce colloque
aujourd'hui à paris le patron de la
brigade criminelle de washington aux
etats unis alors en toute bonne logique
nous avons donc choisi de nous rendre à
washington pour quelques aperçus de la
réalité de son travail
reportage pascal doucet bon michèle
fines et france vaillant c'est le
quartier est de washington une zone
réputée pour la pauvreté de ses
habitants ces dealers de crack et
d'héroïne
pour le sergent diane romer la journée a
commencé de façon presque banal trois
hommes blessés par balles en plein jour
à un arrêt de bus l'un deux seulement
étaient visés par le tireur les deux
autres ont été blessés par ricochet
consiste à tracer le périmètre de
sécurité
il faut qu'on retrouve les douilles les
policiers sont en train d'interroger les
témoins pour avoir un signalement du
suspect dont un policier
le premier finalement
selon les témoins c'est un homme de race
noire portant des jeans et user mais
elle n'a pas le temps de s'attarder
une jeune femme battue par son petit ami
vient tout juste d'appeler le central
dix minutes plus tard c'est une mère de
famille dont le fils n'est pas rentré
cinq à six interventions par heure c'est
en début de week-end normal nous sommes
confrontés est probablement beaucoup
plus souvent que les policiers européens
à des situations très très dangereuse
le danger rôde connaît il est le chef de
la section homicide du district de
washington
trois cent assassinats l'année dernière
et la criminalité a baissé
washington n'est plus la ville la plus
criminogène des états unis fort de ses
premiers succès reçoit pas donc décidé
de confronter son expérience avec celle
de policiers européens
depuis ce matin il est en visite en
france martine monteil et le chef de la
brigade criminelle de paris dans les
bureaux mythique du 36 quai des orfèvres
c'est la première fois que l'américain
et la française se rencontrent pas je
veux rapporter des informations
je veux aussi expliquer aux français ce
qu'on fait aux états unis ils peuvent
choisir d'utiliser ou non ces
informations dans leur organisation
je crois de la même façon je cherche ce
qui en france peut être utile dans notre
système
c'est un échange d'idées et
d'informations aux soupes visera ensuite
la belgique plus il reviendra en france
jusqu'à la semaine réunion du comité
national du parti communiste les
communistes réaffirment leur
appartenance à la majorité plurielle
mais veulent des réformes plus radicale
monsieur robert urbain soir je sois moi
ça doit être un exercice pas facile
facile cet équilibre entre j'appartiens
est intense critique un nom j'appartiens
mais oui critiques parfois nous voulons
que la gauche plurielle réussissent et
les premiers mois de 200 actions à la
tête du pays
on marque des résultats intéressants
significatif mais précisément parce que
ces résultats sont significatifs parce
que on sent un climat un peu meilleur il
faut profiter de cette fenêtre en
quelque sorte pour que s'engage un un
élan plus radicale dans les réformes
voilà l'état d'esprit qui est plus
personnelle parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'entre vos militants qui vous réclame
des réformes des vraies réformes
inscrites dans le programme du parti
communiste
et puis le fait que vous êtes obligés de
faire quand même alliance avec le parti
socialiste
vous êtes c'est un rôle qui est quand
même un peu difficile non je crois que
la base de tous les militants les
adhérents savent et ils en ont décidé
ainsi il y a un an et demi quand nous
sommes entrés au gouvernement
ils savent que on ne vient pas on n'est
pas venu au gouvernement de la france
avec la gauche plurielle pour mettre en
oeuvre la politique du parti communiste
on a on a donc on est là pour être utile
à ce que la gauche plurielle soit bien
ancrée à gauche qui centre de réformes
importantes s'engage or qu'est ce que je
constate aujourd'hui il y à ce climat
dont je parlais mais incontestablement
zagunis la tribune en dit que tout va
bien oui mais oui moi je voudrais dire
de ce point de vue il y en même temps
des millions de français qui continuent
d'être au chômage la précarité qui
existent même si le chômage a un peu
reculé
tout ça reste dur il y à des urgences et
je pense que l'heure est à des mesures
audacieuses
alors il finit évidemment salaire ça
implique qu il y ait une autre
utilisation de l'argent mais je crois
que le moment est venu de le faire
messieurs si vous dites ça c'est que les
socialistes ne font pas c'est que vous
êtes un peu agacé par le fait que yvon
papa trop modestement trop prudemment à
vous avez envie de réforme plus radicale
qui sculpte et je suis communiste et je
ne suis pas socialiste je suis pour
effectivement qu'il y ait plus de
radicalité à la politique à mettre en
oeuvre non pas que je souhaite
m'inscrire une ritournelle permanente
jour plus mais mais quand même
aujourd'hui on voit bien que si nous ne
relançons pas par exemple la
consommation intérieure on a vu qu'avec
la crise internationale la consommation
intérieure c'était quelque chose
d'important qui à part des salaires plus
significatif des retraites aussi des
minima sociaux
eh bien on n'aura pas cet élan
nécessaire pour relever le défi des
défis il y a un défi décisif sur
laquelle la gauche sera jugé c'est le
défi de l'emploi donc faire reculer le
chômage implique des mesures audacieuses
jospin le dis donc vous êtes en
désaccord mais j'ai certes mais achètent
non comprenez bien que healy à ces
millions de chômeurs dont je parlais
tout à l'heure et il y a des petites
avancées mais ça ne suffit pas mais mon
rythme où ça va arranger les riquet ce
qu'il faut faire large mais je pense
qu'il faut relancer son significative la
consommation pour qu'elle soit clair
qu'ils en commun et est bien par une
augmentation des salaires par des
mesures incitatives à l'emploi par
exemple il faut apporter des aides aux
entreprises notamment aux pme pmi mais
il faut systématiquement liés czc
exonérations fiscales et bien de
dispositions visant à créer des emplois
il faut vraiment que l'argent des
français soient utiles à l'emploi et
donc je pense qu'il faut être plus fort
plus pressants il y a le patronat exerce
une pression incontestable sur cinq y en
a mais alors est ce que vous êtes pour
la baisse des charges sociales par
exemple sur les bas salaires
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut être
incitatif est-ce que vous approuvez 7
cette idée qui est dans l'air et qui
devrait être annoncée cette armada
mauvrit d'un peu de temps je ne sais pas
si madame aubry va nous c'est cette
disposition
parce que j'en ai parlé un peu avec elle
il reste que je pense qu'il faut il faut
faire attention que toute baisse des
charges sur les bas salaires n'entraîne
pas un patronat qui est aux aguets à
abaisser les salaires et à faire une
politique des bas salaires qui est visée
bon moi je suis pour des aides d
allègement significatif si entre par
ailleurs il y à des emplois créés moi ça
me gêne pas qu'on ait d'une entreprise
ça me gêne pas qu'il ya une exonération
fiscale pour une entreprise par exemple
sur la taxe professionnelle à position
qu'on prenne en compte la nécessité de
créer des emplois moi vous avez changé
quand même cette annonce ce n'est pas le
discours du parti communiste c'est le
discours du parti communiste
d'entreprise de la maison je sais pas
une
milliards comme un errant dans les
canards les milliards qu'on donnait au
patronat comme ça vous avez souvent
dénoncé ça et maintenant vous dit pas si
on peut les aider s'ils créent des
emplois à terme 1 écoutez je propose des
réponses non c'est un langage tout à
fait réaliste moi je ne veux pas
diaboliser l'entreprise
je souhaite surtout que l'argent des
contribuables argent la richesse créée
puisse aller effectivement à l'emploi
par exemple y faut une autre politique
du crédit beaucoup plus incitatives que
celle qui aujourd'hui est mise en oeuvre
autant d'éléments modernes oui vous oui
je nous sommes porteurs les communistes
aujourd'hui plus que jamais de mesures
fortes innovantes permettant
effectivement de de faire reculer le
chômage et la précarité
c'est notre obsession merci monsieur
verjux le snes fsu principal syndicat
d'enseignants du second degré annonce
qu'il reporte au 24 septembre son mot
d'ordre de grève lancé pour le jeudi 10
septembre prochain la situation est
nouvelle après une longue période de
blocage absolu le ministre discute a
déclaré madame veil a au nom du snes
quelques difficultés cependant pour la
rentrée scolaire en région parisienne
avec des occupations d'écoles primaires
par des parents d'élèves qui protestent
contre des effectifs trop lourde et
fermetures de classes ou des postes non
pourvus c'est le cas notamment dans le
val de marne en seine et marne et dans
les hauts-de-seine
l'une des préoccupations pratiques pour
cette rentrée concerne les livres le
ministre lui-même les trouve trop dense
et les parents d'élèves souhaitent une
réforme dans ce domaine voici un aperçu
contestable de ce que l'on peut trouver
à la rentrée en achetant soit livres
d'occasion soit un livre neuf pour la
même discipline
reportage elisabeth sv philippe liuzzi
deux livres de français à gauche la
première édition à droite la deuxième
conforme nouveau bac si l'on se fie à la
couverture car à l'intérieur on avoue
chercher il n'y a pas de différence ni
dans les schémas ni dans les têtes
l'éditeur a construit une nouvelle
édition en expliquant que c'était une
nouvelle édition conforme alors que
c'est strictement la même que les années
précédentes sur façon un petit peu de
juguler le marché de l'occasion
ici même chose seule la couverture
change quand passer de livres de
sciences économiques
ils ne diffèrent que par la couleur de
certains paragraphes et le tracé de
quelques courbes des courbes bien cher
payé l'édition neuf coûte 131 francs
l'occasion 64 francs
les éditeurs trompe les clients et
semble-t-il les enseignants qui sur les
listes donner aux élèves exigent les
nouveaux manuels mais ils prétendent ne
pas pouvoir faire autrement quand on
prend une ans et une édition ancien
certains collègues se plaignait que les
élèves ne trouvait pas ne trouvez pas
l'édition ciani avait voulu conserver
sur deux ans l'édition en ciel est au
bout de la deuxième année
elle avait été retiré de la vente les
éditeurs ont une autre version
on se renvoie la balle nouvelle édition
quand on a la volonté de d'innover sur
le plan pédagogique parce qu'on sent que
celle des enseignants il ya une attente
pour des ouvrages ou des méthodes mieux
adaptée à l'évolution de la discipline à
leurs pratiques de classe au niveau de
leurs élèves donc ça ce sont des raisons
qui nous font publier de nouvelles
collections
c'est le gâchis tous ces anciens livres
de ton espérait tirer un petit quelque
chose ne sont plus cotés sur le marché
de l'occasion
donc pas repris
j'en avais comme vous voyez une
quinzaine ou une vingtaine j'ai pris en
vente que quatre ça coûte cher en
investissement et puis bon bah après on
est bloqué par là j'ai perdu une belle
somme d'argent quoi safran par livre
lorsque j'ai bien perdu 600 francs
l'entrée en seconde coûte en moyenne
1200 francs rien que pour l'achat des
livres des livres trop dense
la plupart des profs ne travaille que
sur le tiers de leur contenu en
guadeloupe l'inter syndicat des dockers
et l'ensemble des organisations
patronales sont parvenus à un accord la
grève des dockers avaient commencé le 28
juillet dernier
les grévistes ont obtenu des
modifications leurs conditions de
travail et des augmentations de salaires
cet accord met fin à un début de pénurie
de produits de première nécessité en
raison du blocage des ports
une délégation de producteurs de porcs a
été reçu en fin d'après-midi par le
ministre de l'agriculture louis le
pensec pour faire face à l'effondrement
des cours du marché du porc seafrance 04
le kg aujourd'hui des mesures devraient
être annoncées le mystère le vient
d'indiquer ce soir des mesures devaient
être annoncés vendredi
et on parle d'une avance de trésorerie
alors les éleveurs veulent qu'une aide
pour sous forme d'allègement des charges
et principales raisons de cet
effondrement des cours lassus prendre la
surproduction en europe et le fait que
l'un des acheteurs la russie n'est plus
solvable
les jeunes producteurs bretons qui
viennent d'investir dans des équipements
sont donc les plus touchés au porte à
jacques devaux gabriel camilla la nuit
dernière à vannes 200 producteurs de
porcs ont manifesté devant la préfecture
du morbihan
les éleveurs passe à l'offensive alors
que le cours du porc a encore chuté
aujourd'hui pour atteindre 6 francs 04
le kilo dominique a construit un nouvel
atelier il ya un an
investissement 2 millions de francs son
coût de revient s'établit à 9 francs le
kilo au cours actuel il est dans le
rouge et attend au moins une aide sur
les charges sociales
les cotisations sociales sont à près de
37 % du revenu
donc ça fait quand même appartement ou
un éleveur gagne 100 mille francs
annuel il a déjà donné trente sept mille
pour en cotisations sociales donc je
crois que là il faut absolument des
reports de cotisations sociales pour les
agriculteurs les plus en difficulté une
prise en charge de ses intérêts mais si
la crise est là ce n'est pas vraiment
une surprise
depuis le début de l'année les cours
s'effrite la surproduction et générale
en europe en 1998
l'union européenne devrait produire 12
millions de porcs de plus qu'en 1997
alors pour les éleveurs il faut que
bruxelles aide les exportations vers les
pays tiers
il faut dégager de la marchandise même
sur des pays qui ne sont pas solvables
donc là ça demande une aide financière
européenne mais l'exportation ne
résoudra pas tout car la crise est
structurelle pour dominique il faudrait
maîtriser la production notamment en
limitant la taille des exploitations
un choix que tous les producteurs ne
sont pas prêts à accepter y compris en
bretagne reprise des convois chargés de
déchets de combustible nucléaire c'est
convoi avait été stoppée en mai dernier
à la suite d'un rapport de la sûreté
nucléaire
manque de rigueur contre le peu précis
des mesures de radioactivité constate
contamination des convois la sncf avait
préféré arrêter ces transports edf a
organisé des audits internes et organise
maintenant trois séries de contrôle
contradictoire au départ des convois
nous sommes rendus à gravelines dans le
nord c'est là que se trouve la plus
grande centrale nucléaire d'europe pour
constater les changements
reportage marianne masse dominique maes
à l'intérieur de cette grosse guen 12
barres de combustibles nucléaires usés
c'est ce que l'on appelle le château un
défaut de propreté sur cette zone
trop de manipulations et c'est tout le
convoi qui est contaminé dont dangereux
les contrôles ont été renforcés
trois organismes sont aujourd'hui
chargés des mesures nous serons dans
toutes les procédures
procédure les appliquent et aprilia des
services etienne qui viennent avec leurs
procédures pour garder contre le
contradictoire et valider mon propre
possible
chaque année 200 convois de combustibles
usés quitte les centrales edf à
destination du centre de retraitement de
la hague
l'an dernier 35 % de ses convois ont
présenté une contamination de surface
supérieure à la limite réglementaire
un rapport de la sûreté nucléaire a
conclu en mai dernier un manque de
rigueur dans les procédures de
décontamination en france tous les
convois ont dû stopper votre première
réaction a été de déclencher un mot bits
de la friction du père qui est un
service d'audit interne d'edf façon à
jeter un regard externe sur nos
procédures les résultats c'est audit et
techno procédure d'évoquer son
combustible était bonne que ma personne
était compétent que simplement il
fallait rajouter de la rigueur dans la
préparation de ces opérations
et quand le nuclaire manque de rigueur
il y a de quoi s'inquiéter
un plan général d'amélioration des sites
a été mis au point renforcement des
contrôles et de la propreté des convois
protection des wagons pendant la
manutention et meilleurs communication
vers l'extérieur par le biais des
commissions locales d'information
c'est dans la durée qu'il faudra voir
avec de temps en temps des exigences de
retour et on n'est quand même pas mettre
des résultats on peut toujours nous dire
que tout va bien tout va bien les
limites
une question reste en suspens qu'on est
il des éventuels rayonnement des convois
plusieurs syndicats de la sncf ont
réclamé une évaluation précise des
risques encourus par les cheminots
chargé des wagons depuis le mois dernier
les convois ont donc repris le chemin de
la hague sous haute surveillance dans
les bouches-du-rhône à marseille et aix
en provence de très forts orages ont
provoqué aujourd'hui la coupure d'une
autoroute de plusieurs axes de
circulation route à ce contenu
la chaussée était inondée sur 300 m les
confiance fais-tu plusieurs centaines
d'interventions à noter qu'un bulletin
d' alerte puis a été lancé outre le
département des vosges rôle mais
également dans le var
vaucluse les alpes-de-haute-provence et
des inondations notamment à nice
également à nice où se trouve
aujourd'hui l'actuel congrès
d'ophtalmologie c'est dans le domaine de
la chirurgie de l'oeil qu'une nouvelle
expérimentation a été annoncée selon un
chirurgien une même opération au laser
peut désormais être effectués sur les
personnes atteints de myopie comme de
presbytie
il y aurait 18 millions de français
atteints de presbytie stade y voyant mal
de près bien sûr cette nouvelle approche
chirurgicale est encore expérimentale
reportage yasmina ferveur diane richard
madame augusto est décidée elle voit mal
de près elle va se faire opérer de la
presbytie
donc vous avez parinaud dit c'est à dire
l'équivalent de deux dixièmes en vision
de près sans correction c'est votre
presbytie qui nous embêtent d'accord
après le bilan c'est l'heure de
l'anesthésié locale grâce à quelques
gouttes
le matériel utilisé pour l'opération est
un laser baptisé l'asic déjà fréquemment
employé pour les myopies seule nouveauté
au chirurgien niçois a modifié les
données du logiciel de l'ordinateur pour
l'adapter aux presby l'ordinateur pilote
le faisceau laser qui va remodeler la
cornée
nbc ou non me permettre aux filles c'est
vers la périphérie ont fait bomber la
cornée ce qui permet comme un sou fait
de le voir monter et 20 jours qui
viennent on défend très légèrement
baisse tout cela la nuit ne se voit pas
des imams
après l'intervention d'un quart d'heure
les patients récupèrent vite mais la
vision ne se stabilise qu'après deux
mois et la cicatrisation de la cornée
doit être régulièrement surveiller la
méthode et novatrice les spécialistes
ont suivi les interventions en direct
il souhaite une bonne évaluation des
résultats pour comprendre ces mécanismes
la communauté scientifique a besoin de
recul ce qui est très important à ce
stade de la recherche et de la clinique
c'est de s'assurer que toutes ces
méthodes ont une efficacité stable dans
le temps et de comparer ces méthodes
pour essayer de déterminer quelles
méthodes optimale
cette opération coûte douze mille francs
elle n'est pas remboursé par la sécurité
sociale mais le laser n'est pas l'unique
solution au congrès de nice une nouvelle
technique d'intervention à base d'un
plan a été présenté
signe que la chirurgie de la presbytie
est un marché d'avenir en france chaque
année 600 mille personnes découvrent
qu'elles ont besoin de lunettes pour
voir de près sport cyclisme troisième
étape de la vuelta c'est à dire le tour
d'espagne troisième étape entre cadix et
estepona à l'issue de l'arrivée au
sprint comco constate laissé le français
laurent jalabert s'est emparé de la
première place au classement général de
ce tour d'espagne il avait grappillé
quelques secondes cours des
bonifications de cette troisième étape
en football démission de bertie vox le
sélectionneur de l'équipe d'allemagne
l'ancien international avait fait
l'objet de nombreuses critiques à la
suite de l'élimination de l'allemagne
face à la croatie en quarts de finale la
coupe du monde
cinéma festival de deauville priorité
est donnée à la compétition des films
indépendants
mais ce festival du film américain
s'accompagne aussi de célébration plus
littéraire puisque aujourd'hui c'est
mame mary higgins clark qui était
célébrée pour notamment son dernier
roman intitulé tu m'appartiens de quoi
inciter jean-jacques duflot et jean
françois chauvet à suivre de près cette
romancière spécialiste des polars à
succès
nommé comme spielberg mary higgins clark
attire la foule des photographes
normal cette dame c'est la reine que
dis-je l'impératrice du suspense surtout
si on s'intéresse ce tirage est ce que
j'adore c'est notre préféré c'est votre
bonheur beaucoup et ouais elle est
géniale tout ce qu'elle écrit jolie new
yorkaise 69 ans est toujours fringante
mari raconte qu'elle est entrée en
littérature pour pouvoir après la mort
de son premier mari nourrir ses cinq
enfants
ils ne doivent pas être mort de faim
puisque avec ses petites histoires bien
tricoté cette star du polar a quand même
réussi à vendre 250 millions
d'exemplaires un peu partout dans le
monde
largement de quoi se permettre d'être
toujours tiré à quatre épingles
mais soyons justes l'argent ne lui a
apparemment parce qu'il tournait la tête
oui je suis très heureuse d'avoir du
succès je m'en souviens tous les matins
en me levant et d'ailleurs j'ai promis à
dieu de ne jamais être arrogant le
succès de ces livres elle explique en
citant le prix nobel de littérature
isaac singer aussi travailler soit votre
style vous ne serez pas un écrivain si
vous ne racontez pas une histoire
tous devraient toujours commencer par
ces mots magiques il était une fois et
béganne
même si elle est célébrée photographier
et a donné un peu partout dans le monde
sachez quand même que la preuve de ses
livres est toujours la même en résumé
l'inclusion du mal dans le bonheur
tranquille as d'une femme momentanément
ciel du travail de croquis fait
exactement ce que l'on attendait je
crois que les gens s'identifient comme
histoire gars je raconte un quotidien
qu'un grain de sable vient blueberries
dans le champ vous entrez dans un
magasin pendant un cambriolage ou alors
votre vol sur la panam est annulé ou
retrouver sur la suisse air il ya là
dedans toute la fragilité de la vie
apparemment un bon filon puisque 23 ans
après la parution de son premier roman à
suspense le succès est toujours là dans
les librairies clark ça se vend comme
des petits pains là les derniers vous
l'avez 630 pas et ça c'est le dernier tu
m'appartiens un spécial suspense
terrifiant
le célèbre roman but de mary higgins
clark toujours au sommet de son art et
vous misez vous mademoiselle
non mais ma mère ait fana les a tous
beaucoup mais moi non
en france et avec un public
essentiellement composé de femmes marie
king's park a déjà vendu d'un million de
bouquins avec elle pour ses éditeurs il
n'ya plus suspect voilà et ce soit vous
retrouverez à 22h50 les missions d'un
monde à l'autre sur france 2 avec paul
amar paul bonsoir vous êtes en direct de
votre décor célèbre de demande à l'autre
alors je vais t-il se passer ce soir
pour cette première bonsoir claude vient
pour cette première nous resterons
fidèles à l'esprit qui a prévalu l'année
dernière nous donnerons la parole à des
français qui sont confrontés à des
situations parfois graves parfois
incompréhensibles et dont le témoignage
a bien sûr valeur d'exemple nous
écouterons ainsi ce soir dominique
cigogneaux dont le fils guillaume a
disparu en mer cet été
en tentant de sauver des scouts
intégristes naufragés dominique
cigogneaux nous dira ce soir son chagrin
et sa colère après la mise en liberté de
l'abbé cottard nous écouteront également
dans un autre registre
alicia star qui a été interné à
sainte-anne pendant 45 jours dans des
conditions considérées comme arbitraire
nous verrons enfin le dossier délicat de
la garde des enfants après le divorce de
couples mixtes franco allemand nous le
ferons avec cosette lancelin qui se
demandent pourquoi la justice allemande
ferme les yeux sur l'enlèvement par son
mari allemand de leurs deux enfants
mathias et caroline nous le ferons
également avec rosetta chiodi nick se
trouve dans la même situation et avec
karine koch qui est française qui s'est
rendu aujourd'hui au ministère français
de la justice et qui a l'intention de
faire la grève de la faim pour pouvoir
garder auprès d'elle sa fille de 18 mois
ces trois mamans seront sur le plateau
d'un monde à l'autre ce soir en direct
et demanderont de l'aide et des
explications aux représentants de
l'ambassade d'allemagne à paris mais
aussi aux représentants du ministère
français de la justice et du quai
d'orsay explication attendue est
nécessaire à l'heure européenne voilà
claude merci paul le rendez vous c'est
donc à 22h50 c'est ça c'est ça
exactement
merci voilà la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle deux informations que nous
avons développées au cours de cette
édition tout d'abord en russie le nouvel
échec pour boris eltsine car la
nomination peut être unis
monsieur victor tchernomirdine n'a pas
eu lieu elle a été refusée par les
députés russes
et puis amélioration l'état de santé de
monsieur jean pierre chevènement mais le
miz intérieur est toujours dans le coma
dans un instant la météo isabelle
martinet de la pluie et du vent
et puis je sans frontières et donc d'un
monde à l'autre après dernier journal 01
eur 35 bruno roger petit 7h50 demain
françoise d'abord dans les 4 vérités
recevra monsieur alain de le de cet
essai demain 13h carole gaessler rachid
arhab skin habitude à prendre
et puis à demain 20h bonsoir merci
non
je